il commence à prendre forme les travaux
commencés en janvier 2017 avec la
démolition de l'ancienne zone
commerciale se poursuivre
le centre commercial open sky de plaisir
de 31 mille mètres carrés dévoile ses
premiers contours nos 120 en 2 h v la
structure sur le
zone une deux trois et quatre nous
allons attaquer la semaine prochaine les
travaux de structure de la zone 5 le
cinéma ugc
nous avons bouclé tous les appels
d'offres pour les lots clos couvert et
nous allons attaquer dans deux semaines
les appels d'offres pour les loges dr
une trentaine d'enseignants viendra
s'installer dans le centre avec
notamment la marque de prêt-à-porter à
bas prix pride marquent encore peu
présente en france
elle occupera ici une zone entière sur
deux étages mais cette offre mode sera
également complétée par une véritable
offre de restauration et ça c'est
important parce que ça va avec cette
notion de lieu de vie de retrouver des
terrasses de retrouver un des lieux pour
consommer entre amis au moment du
shopping
autre point fort d'open sky un
multiplexe de neuf salles de cinéma ugc
une offre de septième art qui manquait à
la commune de plaisir faut savoir que
nous créons donc 1200 places de cinéma
c'était une attente sur le territoire à
la fois une attente du public mais aussi
une attente des professionnels qui
aimerait renforcer le maillage en termes
de cinéma sur le territoire je rappelle
quand même que le cinéma est aujourd'hui
la sortie culturelle préféré des
français et donc nous sommes contents de
pouvoir accueillir ici
une offre complémentaire à celle qui
existe déjà sur le territoire
le chantier continue son avancée
ouverture prévue fin 2010 9
le centre commercial devrait permettre
la création de 300 à 400 emplois